yes what is your name sir oh hi my name
is Scott and my question is for all of
you guys depending on if you can answer
this what's it like to work with the
original cast of the legends say like
Mark Hamill Harrison Ford and Carrie
Fisher
here's and Donna was wearing the wig
it's how much fun how school it was
going into filming Star Wars I've been
working with the legends that have
gotten I've already made this kind of
universe and coming back to her was
everything we could have hoped for a
more they're funny and warm and
welcoming and made us feel as part of
the universe as they already are so it
was great
excellent job I have to say my greatest
memory was taking Houston for to a
Nigerian restaurant in southeast London
and walking in and seeing all these
Nigerian absolutely further inside the
Paris afford and this guy comes up to a
missus I do have some thought as before
girls I used to be
[Music]
yeah my name is Mario and this is for
the whole panel including peers right if
you guys aren't Jedi's in real life what
color would each of your life savers be
gone I'm gonna go to blue right away
I have to listen I'm gonna say red I
have to say it red it would I would like
to hand the first black eye
[Music]
I'd say gold si silver a rainbow-colored
[Applause]
thank you all right so we've seen the
light side guys haven't seen yet is a
little taste of the dark sides I would
like to bring down some people as kylo
Ren
[Applause]
[Music]
all right well you really match are you
moving to me who are you
I mean we didn't really have a lot of
conversations about bad or evil actually
when we were on the srimant it was more
what do you think is the difference
between being bad and being right I
think which is a huge difference someone
who thinks the van is almost kind of
like a selfish thing and it's mostly
about them and
hurting somebody else you know thinking
what they want but thinking that right
is something different like that's
almost more evil a group of people who
have decided that they're morally
justified in behaving a certain woman
and that I think that's what we kind of
approached it unless like a bad person
Chuck has done it no no character would
really go I am people like they just
want what they want and that doesn't
always Jack what everyone else wants
right Gillian is in the film though I am
evil character I am evil he's British so
yeah
[Music]
using a large weaponized machine to
attain something yeah just like the
British head to toe in Armour how do you
you know get in the way when you're
trying to portray a character and you
have this kind of cumbersome stuff that
you have to work around or do you work
it into the character I'm fighting
because I found it not only exciting
that there was a female stormtrooper but
the opportunity to explore a female
character that is totally not about the
way she looks in flesh and that armor is
exterior and and it's more likely
outside feeding in and I just found it
very exciting the underneath the that
armor is a woman and I think it makes it
really excellent I'm sure you have a
couple of questions for the dark side so
let's let's turn on the light and let a
couple people ask questions nice yes sir
hello it's good to meet the other bad
guys um I wanted to know because I was
it's our celebration and I got to hear
John and Daisy and Oscar story about
their reaction when they were cast in
Star Wars so I'd like to hear the three
new people what was your reaction when
you found out you were going to be in
Star Wars that's what you said no it was
I met with JJ and mr. Lawrence Kasdan
and they told me this the the story and
who the guy was and that he was in
charge of people on historic like
Starkiller basis orderly and oh I know
[Music]
yeah we the the name of the the base of
the the first order is in in honor of
the original last name of the Skywalker
is Starkiller base spoiled by domhnall
gleeson what else do you want to know
what else do you want to know yeah I
just didn't think it could possibly
really happen I felt that when I heard
it was sort of happening and going for
fittings and things I still thought
there's every chance that they could
just replace me with someone else and
every day the most surreal bizarre
experience of we don't like it is for
all of you is it such a part of the
fabric of your being and then you're
suddenly involved in this no I don't
know what it's like to be inside
actually I was just in the car coming
here and kind of realized them hi but it
was Jonathan and what is your question
Jonathan is there going to be any
mention of Darth Plagueis in Episode
seven maybe surrounding a certain staff
that someone finds oh is that clear
clarity all right hey no Larry's messed
up messing with you I don't think you
know we don't we talk about story too
much too soon but I will say no hey
how's it going
sweet how are you good but none I just
want to say your goddess I think your
anymore that short and sweet cast I just
want to know are you run on the light
side or the dark side of the force
you mean real life I just want to know
which is their preference if they had to
choose oh okay let's let's start with
Jon one more dancer oh I wouldn't be
involved in any of the ambiance or
trying to make some money
[Music]
another chaotic good and I'm being a
sidekick
Oscar Adam we're just gonna spend
questions for a second because at this
point I I don't know I thought it might
be kind of fun to bring out Carrie
Fisher
[Applause]
okay what are you doing here what are
the odds
hi Carrie Fisher oh hi my darling how
are you okay okay so can you give us a
little I'm sure even answering this
question a lot but we're all here yes I
was thinking I was afraid to ask but so
my other question is what what was the
feeling like for you when you walked on
the set you saw this all come to life
again I mean I know you you've lent them
a bit for a long time but to see it so
tangibly to be a part of it again what
was that feeling like it was like a
flashback kind of you know I thought
they were right about the acid flashback
to happen take a check and see you know
was just me my voice coming out of my
mouth I know it was we just I always
said it was a little bit like before
only we looked more melton this time
that kind of force melted and did it
feel like you just picked up where you
left up or the DES feeling a new
experience well it's sort of like we
picked up where we left off but we left
off a while ago
so it was a long leave off and then
we're back now there was a certain time
from the three of us were standing
together in it was hard to sort of be
there and then observe an observer so
but we're the legacy players it was
[Music]
[Applause]
before Star Wars came out if you were a
fan convention because that was actually
a part of your life before
what are you telling people about Star
Wars the words come out here I'm in a
space movie I see it like what do you
say at that point well we only have
photographs there was no footage and I
went with Charlie Lippincott and I think
was in Kansas we had r2d2 as a product
we had c-3po although Anthony Daniels
wasn't inside the costume but as you can
imagine with only 25 photographs as
various scenes in the movie it wasn't
really easy to describe what it was but
my enthusiasm for it was just off the
charts and I'm a fan I think my first
convention I ever went to was at the end
after Hotel in 1972 so I was you know
you know I've been a fan since I caught
the black-and-white King calm on
television when I was five or six years
old and I think the fans understand that
I mean I'm you know I'm one of them and
they're obviously over my career they've
been a really important part of my life
and you know because without you guys
were nothing is there anything I mean
this is this is a very momentous
occasion have you guys together on stage
like this mean is there anything a
message that you have an event who've
been on this journey since 1976
is there anything to take away from it I
just like I say the well keep coming
back yes but no you know it's hard to
describe because when I need you on the
street everyone has a story I met my
wife at the premiere of Jedi are my sons
named Luke or whatever it is it's such a
personal connection and it's very moving
to me it's sometimes hard to absorb the
impact could have had it's almost an
out-of-body an experience you know
because it's if I see it put together
it's not me it's Luke but I've never
taken it for granted and like I say it's
it's I'm moved by the the connections in
the world I mean I suddenly become your
friends in the wood to everyone I mean
what my wife and I went to Tahiti on our
honeymoon thinking there's nobody gonna
know about this movie way out in this
paradise and we were on the back porch
of the little hut on the water and I saw
a motorboat coming towards the back
you know coming towards us as it got
closer and closer closer I thought I was
losing my mind because at the at the
town was a guy in the Darth Vader mask
in Tahiti turns out somebody bobbin my
and and and came to Tahiti they were
filming a movie Dino De Laurentiis was
making hurricane and the accountant on
the film had done Star Wars he said you
know what really surprised mark tried
love to his hot in your Darth Vader mask
when you hear people that they come and
they say you know I want you to show my
daughter I wanted to make sure I showed
my change there was something that you
can do as a family I want to make sure
you show them at the right time and then
you watch them like if we don't like the
same character I'm not gonna like my kid
yeah it's a generational thing now so
you know my son and was born when we
were doing Empire Strikes Back now is
he's the real star wars expert in my
family I need to tell you guys I did a
Star Wars trivia contest quiz and
flunked and I said I can't remember what
a console was my bling was it jewels or
no was spices you know you guys now I
think ownership I see the ownership to
the world at large
[Music]
changing how I just since their house is
Harrison okay
is he bitten okay well why don't we see
for ourselves
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry I really have to do this I
apologize I made them all take a picture
backstage and I took a selfie and I
completely blocked Harrison Ford in the
picture like an ass so thank you all
right first of all thank you for coming
out
Harrison
[Applause]
how are you feeling are you feeling good
are you feeling okay yeah I'm fine thank
you very much great they're asking about
your foot my foot just walk good I'm
really appreciative corn ank you for ask
what from your point of view walk
background and said working with JJC
money if I think what wanted all that
feel like it should have felt ridiculous
it was 30 you know 30 years ago and I
sort of grew up and I need here I was
doing something I did so long ago and I
will tell you that it felt great it felt
I wasn't so sure it would but the
company was the right company the
director was the right director Larry
wrote a wonderful story and I was proud
and grateful to once again be involved
you know this the originals of Star Wars
that I was part of really was the
beginning of my working life and was
very very grateful for the opportunity
that I had in that film and for the
success of that film and so it was great
to be back thank you of course I mean
I don't think there was I don't think
there was one person that I knew when we
saw that other footage to be released
not that long ago and you do the we're
home like every two that I knew I felt
like you cried I cried you cried you
write 3 times so you know we all we all
are a part of this as well and it's so
meaningful that three of you agreed to
be in this and really kind of bring us
home all together bring us home I would
love to the audience asked a couple of
questions as I'm sure you're eager to do
so let's start with you Sara hi what's
your name how are you hey Bradley will
do so this is a question for the
returning cast but if any of the other
cast everyone answers well feel free to
do so what stands out to you is the
biggest difference in terms of theme in
this new movie compared to the original
trilogy I don't know that it's a
difference in theme it's a development
of feet and it said and it's a natural
progression of the that has occurred
from from the stories that we told in
the first three and perhaps a you know
an emotional rounding of the experience
that that we all had in the first three
films I was just glad I didn't have to
go to tossing station and pick up any
power converters
I placed information vital to the
survival rebellion and resistances r2
unit I don't want to do that again we
sort of grown up this time I think it
was I didn't have to say it'll take a
few minutes for the navicomputer to
calculate thank you thank you for coming
that's a good question thank you do you
everything for expectations of what your
characters were going to uh
and ever before the movie like where do
you think consul whatever I thought it
was going to be more girly this time and
we were doing a shopping planet facials
very weird laser hair removal well I
don't know I mean when you find out that
the only woman that you really fell head
over heels with is your sister
[Music]
is telling you something so I have a
feeling I probably wind up like Sir Alec
in the first one living in some igloo
out in the desert with her with just in
therapy but with just no human contact
just Joy's you know thing you do is
first question of the day you know my
sister are you no no seriously because
that's I mean we all laugh about it but
can you when you follow it through that
must have been quite the traumatic
experience for my character
[Applause]
you know how many times can I say I'm
sorry my sister my mother
Harrison buin thought about we're on
vitamin Vidal no I'd never occurred to
think about it because I never expected
that it would come back to bless me
rather than haunt me it was I never
thought that we would do another and it
was only you know that I was very
gratified when I read the script because
I think I read something that I thought
was really remarkable really well
well-written and with some very
intriguing developments and so I was
delighted to be involved and I was very
happy to be part of this part of the
story the end the cast again excellent
well I wanted a huge hand for Star Wars
The Force awakens
[Applause]
and I feel like if this wouldn't be the
Star Wars panel then you would be
expecting if we just ended right there
exactly
Amen to you sister so JJ well here's a
question you know obviously besides
these amazing performers on this panel
and again thank you all for being here
there's another significant star of this
series and it's the music who likes the
music to the Star Wars movie so I
wouldn't it be cool if we did something
insane right now who loves to go see a
live Star Wars concert right now
[Applause]
[Music]
we only have four all of you so we're
gonna do something that is truly crazy
and the city of San Diego somehow said
okay to this we are literally all going
to walk to a location together and we
are going to experience a Star Wars
concert tonight
in order for this to work in order for
this to work this has to be done very
carefully and I put all the
responsibility on Chris Hardwick thank
you getting sued okay so here's the very
important thing
here's what you must understand there is
room for everyone no ordering loud
there's no need to push but in a very
orderly fashion outside you're gonna get
one of these and this is going to a new
entrance I first want to quickly
introduce and give a tremendous amount
of respect to a man by the name of Kevin
Doyle I don't know if you saw in Kevin's
story but in memory of his wife Kevin
walked six hundred and forty five miles
from Rancho obi-wan and he's now gonna
finish this walk here with us so Kevin
is here and then
[Music]
[Applause]
and some friends
Kevin I know you thought you were done
we're just gonna make you walk a little
bit more they're gonna follow you so
here's what in order for this to work
everyone has to I know you're taking
pictures you're not listening to me and
I feel like you're my children right now
and I need you to focus okay
pictures pictures pictures okay listen
to me okay good thank you you're gonna
follow these stormtroopers in an orderly
fashion there is absolutely no need to
push because we don't want this to turn
into a tragic event we want to be happy
we're all happy that we're here we're
saying stuff no one's ever seen before
and we're all gonna go see a Star Wars
concert together everyone so please a
little let our panel go would you please
leave to your feet and give me a huge
round of applause for the Star Wars The
Force awakens I'm sorry
[Applause]
and honestly
[Music]
calmly let's yeah they're all gonna go
this way
don't push each other
nanny nanny
me me me me
[Music]